2 qu'est ce que vous avez fait plus fous
par amour vous pour votre à me marier un
enfant c'est ça jean-michel j'ai pris
l'avion pour les à pékin pour une soirée
actionnement nombre est oui mais j'avais
des maïs non je payais pas le billet
j'avais des matchs que j'utilisais pas
et j'avais une copine qui étaient
expatriés à pékin j'ai été la voir le
soir même j'ai pris l'avion le lendemain
matin même je fous et alors dans l'avion
sûr mais c'est sûr et vous est envoyé en
l'air là bas ou dans l'avion mais deux
olala qu'il est beau ou isabelle vous
avez fait à moi je veux consacrer ma vie
vous ne trouvez pas que ça suffit comme
en tout cas vous vous êtes en dépression
vraiment on soir normalement qu'on fasse
un point très rapide de la tête
là vous êtes magnifiques comme ça ça
vous va beaucoup mieux joué que moi tu
irais je vous lis vous êtes beaucoup
plus belles pas tirer vous vraiment à
moi je vous avais déjà raconté il ya un
pote qui m'avait fait une blague j'ai vu
son numéro sur le téléphone de demain
l'a fait en fait il m'a fait croire que
c'était son amant et il habitait à
orléans et je lui ai dit mais je vais
venir je vais que tu es madiba bien je
suis alors des ans tu l'église mérite et
j'ai pris la voiture et je partis sur la
a6 jusqu'à orléans et après arrive à
orléans il m'a dit mais c'est moi je
t'ai fait une blague et j'ai trouvé que
faire de la route comme ça pour rien
faute est gentil orléans républicain moi
avions moi j'ai fait mon gas oil
bien sûr et la paille et le feuillage et
serris pose une question est ce que ce
qu'il a fait c'est de l'amour ou c'est
plutôt de l'amour propre et de la
jalousie
alors vous avez raison je vous bifurque
sur comment ça va
c'est bâle berne phrase qu'il y enlever
l'amour propre de las mujeres pas
grand-chose phrase qu'il y enlever un
chroniqueur de l'émission sera aussi
bien par amour j'ai acheté une tablette
numérique pour son anniversaire mais
dans la stratégie de regarder des films
ensemble le soir c'est ça qui versait et
bresse a h1n1 à junas relais vous avez
regardé et bush expliqué non j'ai rien
en tête
voilà des mercis excusez nous de vous
avoir dérangé directes 9 qui participent
à des chiffres et de lettres
vous avez mieux non j'avais il est jeune
et que si m j'avais encore